the mark of the beast has been the place
of much imagination speculation and fear
in the past decades i remember as a
child hearing that code bars on products
might be
an early shadow of this mark recently
with
rumors of microchips being placed under
the skin
of course the most recent speculation
has been that
the new vaccine is the mark or a step
towards this mark
these intuitions often arrived at
through very immediate ways can
nonetheless divulge a mystery about
what this mark is referring to
in general though this subject has been
the arena of the arena of much panic in
certain circles
while seeming like strange and arbitrary
to others
in the media the reaction of course is
to mock the concerns that people have
to attempt to debunk the claims or else
to simply wonder why it matters
why apart from some verse in revelation
would it matter to be marked in this
matter
why would it bother people the way it
does except for their
religious attachment to this very
strange book full of dragons and
trumpets and floating altars with lambs
on them
what we will see is that although the
relationship between a vaccine
surveillance identification and a mark
that would make you participate or
expelled from a system might seem
arbitrary at first
these intuitions do not appear out of
nowhere but are based on
implications which are already there in
the very notion
of a mark itself so what we're going to
do is we're going to do
a deep dive into the problem of the mark
and hopefully the concerns over this
the concerns over these questions
whichever side you end up on will at
least make better sense
to everybody once we're done going
through this but in writing this i
realized just how big the subject was
and so
this subject will be separated in two
videos this video will deal with
a mark and what its origin is in
scripture
what that origin can teach us and how
it's related to
accounting to technology to
identification and yes
to medicine and in the second video
we'll try to sparse out how all of this
is connected to what
is going on right now what we're going
through
and why both the projects and the fears
take the shape that they do
and he the beast causeth all both small
and great
rich and poor free and bond to receive a
mark
in their right hand or in their
foreheads
and that no man might buy or sell save
he that had the mark
or the name of the beast or the number
of his name
here is wisdom let him that hath
understanding count the number of the
beast
for it is the number of a man this
number is 666.
i've talked about the symbolism of the
beast and of 666 in previous videos and
how the
system of 666 is about a desire for
perfection
a desire to account for everything even
the exception
and the effect that this thrust has
now we will see how all of that is also
present in the notion of a mark
so in order to understand the mark of
the beast we must first and foremost
understand what a mark is
this question of the mark is actually
extremely difficult so everybody needs
to strap themselves in
it's one of those subjects which is
actually opaque and difficult
ironically because it is very simple
and it has far reaching implications
elemental symbol symbolism like this is
often taken as a given
and so we have to make a particularly st
a particular style of effort
we have to enter in a type of innocence
in order to perceive the reason
and the function of a mark in scripture
there is an early genesis story
related to the question of marx and it's
in a way
a key to how the mark of the beast is
presented in the book of revelation
the origin of the mark is found in the
figure of cain
after cain killed his brother god curses
him
and humanity's first mark will play a
role in that curse
behold thou has driven me out this day
from the face of the earth
this is cain speaking and from thy face
shall i be hid
and i shall be a fugitive and a vagabond
in the earth
and it shall come to pass that every one
that findeth me
shall slay me and the lord said to him
therefore whosoever slayeth cain
vengeance shall be taken on him
sevenfold and the lord set a mark upon
cain
lest any finding him should kill him and
cain went out from the presence of the
lord and dwelt in the land of nod
on the east of eden and cain knew his
wife
and she conceived and bear enoch and he
built a city and he called the name of
the city
after the name of his son enoch so the
elements in the text are as follows
cain does not accept that his brother
abel's sacrifice is pleasing to god and
so
he kills him god chases cain away to be
a wanderer
so kane complains that this will bring
about his death because
whoever finds him will just kill him and
so god declares that cain will be
avenged if
killed and places a mark on him so that
others
would recognize him and not kill him
kane is chased further away from the
garden knows his wife
has a child builds the first city and
then names the city
for his child the pattern of the story
of cain
follows nearly exactly the fall of adam
and eve
only just at what we could call a lower
and more explicit level
adam and eve don't accept being
forbidden the tree of knowledge
which would make them like god and so
they transgress by eating the fruit of
knowledge of good and evil
plunging them into duality
this seemingly immutable duality will
become the motor for death
and the fall the first fruit of duality
is to notice nakedness
that is to see and to feel threatened by
clear
and irreducible separation between me
and
pretty much everything else they see
themselves as
lacking needed to be added to from the
outside
while also paradoxically experiencing
inside and outside as
incompatible experiencing outside as a
danger
so when we see the story of cain in this
light we realize that killing your
brother
is an increase in the fruit of duality
that is the capacity now to see the
other human as so completely outside
yourself
as to be able to take his life
in the case of adam and eve they're
chased from the garden into the world of
death for their transgression
but god gives them garments of skin
condescends and compensates their
duality
just like god will give cain a mark an
aspect of death itself which protects
them from death
so adam knows his wife they have a son
cain who will as we've just seen
replay the same drama in his own terms
we could say at a lower level through
murder kane city will then also be
another rehash of the pattern at a even
lower level of reality when we say lower
you have to imagine it
lower on the great mountain of being on
the mountain of paradise
as they are chased from paradise they go
down they move from the unity of the top
to the
multiplicity at the bottom and so this
is bringing it closer to
quantity by bringing the fruit of
duality into a social sphere
as the number of people are increasing
on the earth
the strangeness of this can help graft
to what extent inside
and outside are two sides of the same
problem of duality
so the mark of cain just like the
garments of skin because they
participate in duality itself
will strangely down the line become the
common origin of things which we usually
understand as being opposites from each
other
such as tribal inclusion or exclusion
or else something like identity and
strangeness
the structure in the story of cain shows
us how death
increases in the world the marked
received
is a participation in the consequence of
the curse
while also being a protection from the
effects of the curse
while also even inviting a possible
increase
of the effect of this curse so you see
that so the mark sets of
cain as being excluded we could say
akin to dead in a way thrown out further
into the wilderness further into
the outer darkness we could say so
that's the curse that's the curse
of cain so the mark also signifies
how cain is protected from death when he
is recognized by the mark
now if he's killed there will be an
increase and a multiplication of death
in the world because cain will be
avenged sevenfold which is an increase
of the curse
and we learn later that his descendant
lamech who
actually according tradition to
tradition is the one who
accidentally killed cain says he will be
avenged
77 times so we can see how the curse the
promise and the vengeance of death is
growing
from one to 77 from seven times to 77
times
all this promise of death is actually
far worse than if cain
just hadn't been marked in the first
place
so this is the process of the the
supplement which i've discussed
in many videos and which is the duality
of any
increase in power it's easier to
understand with the garments of skin
or with technology rather than with a
mark but
you'll see the mark will become clear in
time as we go through the examples
so if we start with the garments though
we imagine that you live in a kind of
paradise where there's no danger
for some reason i need to move away from
that ideal into a threatening world
i go somewhere where it's cold far away
from this
ideal place let's say both in space and
in situation so what i can do is i can
supplement my body by adding layers and
layers of
clothing to keep myself warm so in doing
so
i'm both marking a type of strength
because this
addition of layer this supplement will
in fact
help me face the increased danger but it
also marks
a type of weakness remember when you
were a kid
and you didn't like wearing a helmet
when you were riding your bike
because of course wearing clothing in
the cold is a mark
that you would be cold without them it
shows
what would make you weak so like the
mark of cane clothing or a wall is both
a consequence of danger
while being a protection from danger and
just like the mark
it is also an invitation to increase the
effects of danger
so if near to my ideal world my tropical
paradise
a lack of clothes might have caused some
mild discomfort for me
now when i come to the dead of winter in
a place where it's very cold
losing what by then would be layers and
layers of warm clothing
will bring about much greater
consequences
so the process of supplement is
difficult to limit to
a specific point in time or space
because it's rather
a process which embeds itself at all
levels
we can recognize the elements and the
patterns of this supplement
but the origins of the pattern go back
they go back onto logically and
historically
into something like a hidden origin
so we can't point to a place or time in
our world of death
where there is no supplement because our
very birth and biological existence are
part of this
ever receding memory rather we can only
point to something like a nostalgia of
innocence and purity
but we would call it a nostalgia for
paradise
we can also recognize this process as
fractal
so something which is actually
relatively less
engaged in this process of supplements
for example
imagine how the human singing voice even
though it's already bound in
exteriority and death appears
nonetheless as an image
of the ineffable paradise compared to
those those other things you can imagine
that are bound up by
layers and layers of addition so let's
say an electronic keyboard for example
so in this case a human voice will
appear more direct and not as encumbered
as the complex electricity powered
keyboard which requires many layers of
languages and and and and buffers in
order for it to even work
so it's always about fractal levels but
the supplement the garments of skin
are inevitable in the fallen world
so what clothing does for your body what
the city does for the social element
the mark does for identification and
knowledge
so if you were searching for the origin
of writing in scripture the mark of cain
would be your best bet this might seem
like a surprise
to many but it's completely coherent
with every use of writing
that has existed since the invention of
writing just like the development of
technology is a working out of the fall
and death working out of the problem
of duality to put a mark on something
is to make it stand out from other
things to separate it from other things
it's akin to appointing or calling out
that one you know that's what a mark
inscribed but now it describes it
on the exterior exteriorly it's
actually different from pointing or
naming which is immediate and done with
presence and we find as
the way in which god even creates the
world marking is something like the
memory
of pointing or calling though it's not a
living memory
it's an exterior memory you could say
the mark acts as a token
to the invisible difference in quality
which came about
by the act of selecting itself so let me
give you an example
so let's say i go to a theater and i
want to keep my place while i'm getting
popcorn
i'm gonna leave my place and when i look
at it all the places are the same so
what i need to do
is i need to mark it somehow so i'm
gonna leave my shirt on it or my book
so that i can remember when i come back
and others can also know
that even though i'm not there this
chair among all the other chairs which
look alike
is my chair it has an invisible quality
the quality of being mine at the moment
a quality that the other chairs do not
have
so i mark it so it can be understood in
my absence
but what makes it difficult to keep this
very simple notion in our mind is that
this calling out that separating
from other things can be good or bad
it can be done for the inside or for the
outside
so a simple mark can mean something like
this
or mine or it can mean good or else you
know for this use
dedicated but it can also mean
not this or rejected or defective
so let's say let's say something like a
urinal is broken
in the bathroom in a public bathroom you
know the people that are responsible
have to market somehow
to avoid someone using it has will have
to separate it from the others in a way
that you'll know that it's different
from the others
so if you want to think of a place where
the duality of this process
appears simultaneously think for example
of
when you were going to school and a
teacher would grade your paper
and would put green and red marks each
meaning the opposite of the other
despite just being check marks on a
piece of paper
so this inside outside duality this is
the very shape of the fall
and it can be found in several aspects
of the story of cain
so cain is cast out and set to wander in
the land of nod a land of hostility
and in reaction to that he develops a
city
then techne technology the arts
and so his seed the seed of cain
contains both
opposites of wild and civilized
something that is contained fixed
identified and something that is
unmoored
wandering and exiled so both of these
extremes
are in the mark itself
marking is always a making of both
inside
and outside the mark is very close to
the idea of a wall or a limit
which can be used to set aside some
space for good
or ill in multiple ways to make sacred
for example like a temple
we will bind it in a space or to keep
excluded
like a prison which we will also bind
into space
keeping in or keeping out can also each
be for good or for ill each
keeping in because each keeping in is
always
simultaneously a keeping out that's why
there is a relationship between a mark
and
something like a seal placed on a
container to bind several things
together
therefore creating an identity of
purpose
this reminds us it brings us to this
notion that the earliest writing we have
these
really early cuneiform tablets were most
often a form of accounting and this
might seem
surprising to those of us who believe in
the sacred origin of scripture but this
accounting
is in many ways already what is
happening in the story of
cain and if you watch my video on the
symbolism of 666 you will remember
the relationship between the system of
the beast and
accounting for everything we can see
that accounting
is the most primordial form of writing
and mark making
because it is first about including and
excluding
then about quantifying sets of things
bound
by an identity whether by category
or by owner so we take a bunch of things
and we we account for them we place them
in a in a container with the name on it
or we put them on the list with the mark
next to it so we can understand that
they're related to each other
it's the place where purpose quality and
quantity
are bound by an authoritative an
authoritative system
so we need to understand the mark of
cain as both the origin of writing
and the origin of mathematical notation
at the same time
this little insight about how marx
served to account for something
can already show in all there is to
understand
about the mark of the beast in
revelation which as you
remember can be a number or can be
a name the name of the beast in order to
more properly understand the
relationship between the mark
writing and the garments of skin we
actually need to take a little detour
into plato actually we need to take a
detour into plato
and to and into the philosopher jacques
de geada
in this very famous work called plato's
pharmacy
jacques derida stumbles into the
question of the supplement
and although i think he makes some
serious errors in his
conclusion he appropriately draws
attentions
to his importance in his reading of
plato's dialogue
phedris he analyzes the multiple
meanings of the word
pharmacon farmicon is a greek term
which is equivalent to the english word
or similar to the english word drug
meaning both a poison and a cure
at the same time with the general notion
that a drug is a supplement it's
something
it's an addition of some exterior thing
to yourself
one of the derivatives of the word
pharmakon is pharmacos
which refers to human sacrifice the
ritual scapegoat sacrifice
so a deficient person was either
expelled from the city or else
expelled and killed and so there is a
relationship here to
this girardian notion of identity
forming through scapegoating
which already happened in cain killing
abel but
then is also happening for the line of
adam
and seth in the expulsion of cain from
their midst
we can see that scapegoating is already
part of
identity making right at the beginning
of genesis
another related word pharmaceus which
deida
also brings into the discussion will
mean a poisoner
but ultimately something like a magician
or sorcerer
of course in the very ancient world
there is very little difference between
a tecton
artisan someone who who creates things
and a magician in the sense that both of
them
are directing knowledge towards
increasing power
over the world rather than using
knowledge uh
in order to acquire more wisdom this is
why the fallen angels in the book of
enoch
teach both teach all at the same time
metallurgy
necromancy and even the power of
seduction
so going back to plato's fidris in this
dialogue we find
socrates and fijra his friend
encountering each other outside the city
and then they cross a river to discuss
desire
to discuss sex love as madness
and anyone who is aware of any story
from hercules and the centaur to elijah
and the chariot or
to saint mary of egypt will understand
the relationship between
crossing the river and entering the
wilderness
and the entire dialogue of fidris is
about the problem
of exteriority and ultimately the
question of supplement
in the second part of the dialogue
socrates says that
writing is a dangerous pharmacon
as we mentioned a supplement to speech
which must be rejected or at least seen
as
suspect in making his point
socrates retells the story of an
egyptian god
a foreign story we could say in its own
right
he tells the story of toth or tooth one
of the egyptian gods of the underworld
known for being the origin of all the
arts and technology
and we see his presenting of writing to
the god king
thames so in this story tooth presents
writing
as a supplement a farmicon to wisdom
and memory a way of increasing them by
recording them so thamis on the other
hand sees writing
as the opposite of this and sees it
rather as a weakening of memory
and a decrease in wisdom because now
people
will rely on something external from
memory
and therefore will forget things more
than before
so of course this is the process of the
garments of skin which i've been
describing
from the beginning and it's easy to
understand not only in terms of writing
but
as a basic the basic problem and issue
of technology
the fact that i have my parents phone
number written in my phone
means that i don't have to remember it
in my mind and having a multitude of
phone numbers in my
phone means that i can also access all
all the more people with ease making me
far more powerful
than if i didn't have my phone but it
also means that i'm dependent on my
phone now
and if i lose it i'm in a much worse
position
than i was when before i had a phone
when i just remembered my parents phone
number
through socrates's egyptian stories we
can understand
how the notion of pharmacon can be
translated as
medicine or elixir which is why we still
have the term
pharmaceutical today which is derived
from the same
word so what tooth is presenting to
thamus
is a medicine for memory
and like for writing we understand the
duality of medicine especially
in the common word drug you know i can
take a painkiller to reduce suffering
or i can take coffee to stay awake but
in doing so
it means that my resistance to pain will
decrease in relation to the painkillers
and i might become dependent on coffee
to stay awake
so if one looks carefully one will find
that in the very fact that the story of
tooth is a foreign story a story
from egypt actually structurally
participates
in the notion of the supplement as the
this dead garment this added garment
this outer and excluded aspect
and interestingly enough we will find
this paralleled in
such people as saint gregor of nisa who
uses the image of the egyptian
as the garment of skin itself in his
life of moses
saint gregory relates the egyptians to
the foreskin which must be removed
in circumcision returning us to this
hidden
center but we can also understand the
egyptian as the warriors was chariots as
we
hear in the song of the wars which with
chariots that are covered in the waters
and this
is representative of civilization and
technology
that gets lost in the crossing of the
waters
it's a little image of the flood and how
the descendants of cane
with all their civilization all their
weapons all their metal making
metallurgy and and and cities cain who
also became the first stranger
perished in the waters of the flood
circumcision the removal of this
peripheral skin
just like the drowning of the egyptians
functions like
a basic scapegoat ritual the notion of
farmicon is bound up in the story of
cain with all its element
in fact we find in the story of cain a
verse
a virgin which is purer and clearer than
the tooth story stole
told by socrates as it simultaneously
contains the opposite directions of this
supplement that i'm telling you about
this plays itself out in the story
especially if we understand
the story of cain in the wider tradition
of course of the watchers and the
nephilim in the book of enoch
there the negative element of this
increase in power is attributed
to fallen angels who give this
information to humans
this is actually not unlike the vision
of a god of the underworld like
toth and socrates is myth of the origin
of writing
or for that matter a titan like
prometheus in the greek version which
brings techne and fire to the humans
the elements of the supplement are
contained in kane almost
as an aporia as a this kind of
mystical uh contradiction we could say
which actually makes it difficult
to see them the extreme duality of
inside and outside is brought together
in one character
kane is both a scapegoat marked as
excluded
and the founder of a city one has as a
consequence of the other
he's both a wanderer and the father of
all the arts and technology
the origin of both agriculturalists and
nomads in the mark of cain we also see
another aspect of what is presented
by plato in the feeders dialogue that is
an origin of writing which is also both
a medicine and a poison all at once
so before we go any further i think it's
important to understand that this
process that
this process of the garments of skin
this expansion of
death can be transformed can be
transmuted
and even sometimes reversed and this is
what god will do
in the consequence of the fall
constantly this is
constantly what god is doing and this is
necessary to consider when one
understands that god is not
outside you know it's not outside some
arbitrary creation which is just going
along its way
while he gets involved like this once in
a while
rather god as say maximus tells us and
the whole christian tradition
tells us is the secret origin and tell
us of all things his
energies are actively underlying the
entire cosmos
and so he's constantly calling fallen
things to himself making it
possible once again for them to become
aspects of his glory
by transforming them so we can see this
transformation of the dead supplement
into participation by looking at a few
parallel stories
in the bible so for example when god
serves
israel from egypt and leads them to the
holy mountain after crossing the waters
what we're seeing is a new beginning
it's a new world that's beginning
and moses that goes who goes up the
mountain is actually
an image of a return to paradise a
return to eden
which was itself pulled out of the
primordial waters just like
this new this new israel receiving the
law of god is pulled
out of the crossing of the sea so the
crossing of the sea and the ascent
of the mountain is also akin to
noah's flood which ended if you remember
on a mountain and on this mountain noah
will receive
also a law we often forget that noah
receives a simpler virgin
a very basic version of the law that
moses will
receive later with let's say in much
more
detail and all of these stories are
connected by the same pattern
so in moses's revelation on the mountain
he receives
the law which will be written on stone
tablets
he also received the pattern of the
tabernacle
so when moses comes down from the
mountain now from this new beginning
this new origin
he must wear a veil to cover his face
because of its glory for having
countered god
now remember that adam and eve when they
came down
the mountain of paradise also had to
wear
a veil had to wear garments of skin to
protect themselves now
in the case of moses this veil is also
the supplement
it's a more subtle version of the
garments of skin which were given to
adam and eve
when they were chased down the mountain
of paradise as i just said
but this supplement is not only in the
veil in fact
the veil is in many ways the written law
itself and not only the law but the
earthly tabernacle
built by bezalel in a holiab which has
its own
hierarchy of veils which are leading
into the inner
holy place so this process of
supplementarity of these adding of veils
of these
coming down with a written text a series
of veils which lead to the holy of
holies
if it's not taken as a good in itself
let's say as a means to increase
one's power and pride like cain did it
can actually become
the very procession of layers from the
divine to man
it's a reframing of the supplement
towards
participation it's actually showing the
secret
of what it can be in god so the veils in
this case the writing of the law
always both conceals and reveals it
covers
and shows and so the law
being a good is nonetheless an answer to
the fall
like writing and city building so this
exterior is insufficient in itself right
it's good if it's connected to god but
it's insufficient in itself and
in some ways it can be dangerous
it's a it's dangerous if it's not taken
as a veil which covers
something behind it which connects it to
something behind it something inside
this ontological hierarchy which recedes
into the heart or
recedes into the holy of holies or
recedes up into the mountain where
we encounter god
recedes ultimately we could say to the
divine spark behind reality which is god
himself and so as a form of
manifestation of god
then it becomes a good
this can help us understand for example
the way that saint paul
talks about the law in the book of
romans how the law
shows us the reality of the fall by
making us
transgress particular rules like a
series of veils
reminding you that you are not in the
holy of holies
it can also help us understand how
sacrifice in city building is
how it's presented in scripture so
people today
modern people love to quote psalm 51
which it is said about god
you do not delight in sacrifice or i
would bring it you do not take pleasure
in burnt offerings my sacrifice o god
is a broken spirit a broken and contrite
heart
you god will not despise this of course
is the notion that exterior action is
not
what god wants what god wants is a
broken
spirit a contrite heart so all must
begin in what is invisible and above
which is what spirit is of spirit comes
from heaven comes
from above it is invisible and then the
center
the heart or the place where exteriority
disappears in the holy of holies and
in this hidden place our basic kind of
new age gnosticism likes the idea that
you know all these outer forms don't
matter it sounds spiritual but not
religious
you know we talk about being saved by
faith but not works that kind of thing
but people often forget that there's a
next part
in the psalm so just after this it says
to god again mate please you to prosper
zion
to build up the walls of jerusalem then
you will delight in the sacrifices of
righteousness inburnt offerings
offered whole then bulls will be offered
on your altar so recovering the spirit
that which is invisible and the center
that which is the source and the origin
of multiplicity
lead then to multiplicity to their
exteriorization
the second part of the psalm is
structured the same way as the first one
that we that we quoted but now only in
the world of manifestation
the mount zion is the hierarchy of
heaven embodied on earth
which prospers which always remembers
that the mount
and always remember that the mountain is
is always paradise it's always eaten
and the center gives place to the margin
the walls of the city that are built up
and always remember that the city is the
fruit
of cain but here it's seen as built by
god
himself and so participating in his will
remember when we get further down into
revelation
that the new jerusalem the heavenly
jerusalem descends from heaven it is
built by god himself we could say
and once all of this is done once the
heart is entered the mountain the
hierarchy
prospers the walls get built then the
righteous will offer
sacrifice because the outward gesture
will be completely connected to the
inner movement
so let's be clear the outer gestures are
the same
the garments of skin on the tabernacle
are of the same nature as the garments
of skin on adam and eve
yet they are transmuted into a
participation in glory
by their connection to the invisible
center
and reason for things
the writing on the tablets of the law
are a continuation
of the mark of cain yet now they carry
the will of god into the particular
through multiple prescriptions and
understanding this seriously can help us
understand
so much of what seems ambiguous in
biblical symbolism
for example alluding again to the mark
of the beast
it is said that the mark will either be
on the hand
or the forehead now this statement about
the mark of the beast
actually refers to a commandment in the
old testament
which that we should wear that we should
bind or we should be marked by
the prescriptions of the divine law on
our foreheads or on our hands
exactly where the mark of the beast is
said to go
so the profound duality of these layers
and supplements makes
this symbolism difficult to hold in our
mind i'm sure you're struggling even to
get through this video
one of the best examples which will show
the duality
and its difficulty is that even the
removing
of a veil removing of this
exteriority in a certain way can also be
availing that is it can also be an
exterior sign or mark
of something which is happening at a
more primordial level
and so circumcision is precisely the
removing of the garments of skin
remember removing a layer of skin to
expose that which is hidden
underneath in scripture this gesture is
called a mark actually it's a mark or a
sign but it's the same
word which is used to describe the mark
of cain
but now this mark is one which makes one
enter into a covenant with god
marks one as part of the chosen people
by removing
the outer skin but this gesture which is
actually a removing of the outside
will later be revealed interpreted by
saint paul
as to be a kind of exterior action a
kind of farmicon
an outer gesture meant to reflect an
even more
inner reality which is what which is the
circumcision
of the heart right the center that was
talked about in the psalms
all of this is is is a similar move as
we just saw
right now like i said in psalm 51.
of course this might seem to sound like
a contradiction but this is the
nature of the duality of inside and
outside
and all of this is already there in the
story of cain
because the removing of cain from the
point of view of cain
is an adding of layers as he gets a mark
as he increases the garments of skin to
city building
so he is adding layers onto himself
but from the point of view of god or
from the point of view of adam
the the the casting away of cain
is something like a circumcision cain
has been
cut off he has become the scapegoat
he's become something akin to the
foreskin which is removed
to keep the the line of seth
the line of adam pure and holy
so obviously there would be a lot more
to say on this
but we need to remind ourselves that
we're moving towards an understanding of
the mark of the beast
and how it relates to what is happening
around us
those of you who have been attentive if
you've been able to pay attention
through this difficult video
i will admit will already notice an
interesting
pattern if one looks at the mark of cane
as an aspect of these garments of skin
as this
supplement and with a little help from
plato's use of the
term pharmacon we see the mark as
instigating
several things you see the mark as
instigating
a form of official identification
a way to identify cain a form of
scapegoating
writing civilization but there's also
a medical magical aspect to the mark in
the most gener
general sense of a seal or a talisman or
also
as a remedy which is at the same time
a poison so looking
at this this story of cain as the
beginning of a pattern
we can then understand through the
fractal nature of reality
that this moment of the mark of cain
can be expanded to different levels of
being and
ultimately it can be expanded into its
cosmic finality we could say here final
historical version
and that's exactly how we need to
approach
the illusions in revelation to first of
all
to the beast as a as the final
tyrannical vision of
to the number of the beast as the final
accounting of this system
and the mark of the beast as the
ultimate mark
of inclusion and exclusion
it is the final human mark of inclusion
and exclusion in many ways that is
without the mark one will be excluded
from even the basic participation in
civilization
from buying selling just being part of
human civilization but the mark will at
the same time be a form of apostasy
and will cut one from the face of god
as is mentioned in genesis for cain
but in the image of the mark and the
consequences of cain's fall there are in
fact two possibilities
of the supplement which appear
and which is seen in revelation one that
remembers
and one that forgets one that is
connected
and one that is disconnected cain's
story will
feed the origin of the two final images
in scripture
surprisingly enough the image of the
[ __ ] and the beast in revelation
who come out from below come out from
the sea as we mentioned
already but also the image of the new
jerusalem which comes down
from heaven we could call it the final
city with all that implies
sharing an origin with the city of cain
though covering
and fulfilling the consequences of
cain's transgression
to its glorious resolution by god
himself
there's a hint interestingly enough of
how this problem of the supplement can
be resolved
also found in plato's fidris dialogue
at the very end of the dialogue after
they have talked about the problem of
writing the problem
of the supplement when it's time for
socrates and phedras to return home
socrates offers a prayer he offers the
prayer to pan
and to the unknown gods which haunt this
outside place but
this prayer you'll see could easily
easily be a prayer
for any of us today and he says
give me beauty in the inward soul
and may the outward and inward man be
at one it is in fact the
unity of the inner and outer which is
not only the root of symbolism but also
the solution to the problem of layers
we can see that this prayer is akin to
what we say in our own
prayers we say
as heaven on earth as it is in heaven we
ask god to make it on earth as it is in
heaven this is exactly what socrates
is expressing but now from the heart the
center to the periphery
rather than from above and below but we
saw in the images
in the psalms that these two are very
much akin to each other
so after that socrates asks for
temperance and
temperance and being and temperance and
having
but the last part is very interesting
because fetus answers with another
version
of the solution to the supplement you
could say a mirror of the first
he says to socrates ask the same for me
for friends should have all things in
common
it is in fact through communion of the
particulars that the whole becomes
something true
it is by coming together both within
ourselves but also with those around us
that all
our intentions and our exterior forms
line up to become a crown
of glory so i wanted to give you a
little bit of hope
in my video so in finishing i want to
help people remember
that things don't happen arbitrarily
they follow patterns and this is true
as much in the most factual working out
of what is going on
but also we see patterns in the stories
people tell
and even in the rumors which swarm and
swirl around events
both large-scale rumors but you know
that bubble around
events but also the official propaganda
which emanates from authorities
all of if we pay attention all of these
because they have to engage in
storytelling
can help us understand what is the
narrative frame
which is being brought and sometimes
imposed
on a very complex situation
so all the discussions of vaccines of
identification
of exclusion with its relationship to
economics and accounting
hopefully already for you they won't
appear
as simply arbitrary they are deep
narrative
reasons why these things are happening
the way they are
there are also deep reasons why very
reasonable people are noticing
how the recent events are circling
around and are aiming closer to what in
revelations is called the mark of the
beast
so hopefully after this video you will
understand
a little more why that matters
so in my next video which i promise you
will be less difficult
we'll be more we'll look more closely at
what is happening today
look at the rumors the propaganda the
narratives but we'll also be looking
at the prophecies of a saint saint
paecios
and how many of these threads these
narrative threads have been floating
in the story world for quite a while now
and this covet situation is is actually
not that new in terms of narrative so in
the meantime i pray
that you all have proper discernment in
these difficult times so thank you for
your attention
and i'll talk to all of you very soon